the One Piece manga has just revealed
vegapung's dream to create free
Limitless energy for the entire world
and dropped a major hint that this lost
ancient technology is directly connected
to devil fruits and speaking of devil
fruits from a long time ago for the
first time after 10 years we do see Rob
Lucci in his Zone leopard form
encountering his Arc Nemesis Luffy and
as it turns out these two events are
actually directly connected to each
other dagapunk's dream and research
about the Limitless energy source are
the main reason that emu and the gorosei
have ordered his assassination and
ordered zp0 to Egghead island in the
first place now we've already speculated
that the world government was after
vegapunk because of his knowledge of
ancient technology from the ancient
Kingdom by the way this is something
that's always kind of bugged me a little
bit because the name ancient kingdom is
actually kind of a mistranslation in
case you don't know in the original
Japanese it's actually called the
kyodina which translated means the
gigantic Kingdom not the ancient Kingdom
but you know I've always thought gives
the name a totally different vibe I mean
ancient sounds pretty cool too
admittedly but gigantic makes it sound
even more impressive and Global than
ancient I personally would say now the
Vicky has corrected this to the great
Kingdom but again kildai means enormous
or gigantic which is completely
different from even great and it's not
only the adjective that's kind of wrong
here I think the translation ancient
Kingdom has also created the impression
amongst Western fans at least that the
ancient weapons are part of the ancient
Kingdom something that we actually don't
know for a fact I mean of course yeah
they could have been weapons owned by
Joy boy but it's also possible that the
ancient weapons were created by someone
else much earlier and they could even
turn out to be what destroyed the
ancient Kingdom in the first place which
I guess would explain why emo uses what
scene to be the ancient weapon Uranus
now I'm not sure if this translation
mistake was made because both the
gigantic Kingdom and the ancient weapons
date back from the void Century or
because kildai gigantic and kodai
ancient sounds so similar okay sorry for
that little rant but I do think it's
kind of important here though because
vegapunk uses kodai in this chapter
twice to describe the ancient energy and
the ancient machine Soldier now I don't
know about you but to me that sounds a
lot like this ancient robot as well as
the three ancient weapons were all
powered by this unlimited ancient energy
that vegapunk is looking for so
desperately I mean those three actually
do share a common naming scheme unlike
the gigantic Kingdom and I do believe
that this mysterious ancient energy is
connected to the power of devil fruits
or more specifically to one specific
devil fruit okay so vegapunk's dream to
create Limitless free energy for the
world is actually fired by another
famous inventor while vegapunk is
already inspired by Einstein look wise
and has the apple on his head as a not
to Newton his dream is that of Nikola
Tesla The Man Who revolutionized
technology and basically laid the
foundation for our modern
technologically advanced Civilization
now in case you don't know just like
vegapunk Tesla also dreamed of a world
where unlimited energy could be
wirelessly made accessible to all to
create a better world for people
everywhere and end the toxic side
effects of fossil fuels for both humans
and the planets and so one of Tesla's
most extraordinary experiments in this
regard was to transmit electrical power
over long distances without wires or
cables all Wireless he was actually
planning to build a gigantic Tower using
this technology that would be able to
spread free electricity all around the
globe apparently his investor at the
time was JP Morgan's pulled all his
money from Tesla as a result of that
proposal he actually owned companies
making everything from cables to wires
to phone poles to fossil fuel generators
and so he had absolutely no interest in
financing a project that could result in
free electricity was Tesla's technology
real well he did invent a ton of stuff
that worked and it is rumored that the
US government confiscated most of his
research after his death so we might
never know if it was real or not what's
important for us here is that the
parallels to one piece are clear as they
the world government of One Piece just
like the US government allegedly would
have no interest whatsoever in free
unlimited energy for the entire planets
for over 800 years the godose have
worked hard to keep the people of the
world stuck in basically the 1700s
technologically which makes the world a
lot easier to control for them now
vegapunk is trying to ReDiscover this
energy from its use during the 4th
Century similar to how Nikola Tesla by
the way was set to believe that the
Great Pyramids of Egypt were actually
ancient power plants that also created
unlimited clean energy as you can
probably tell I'm personally very much
fascinated by Tesla and his work which
has been getting a lot more attention in
recent years and I do think that he's a
fantastic inspiration for vegapunk's
character however you might be surprised
to learn that this is not only true in a
positive but also very much in a very
negative way as well I mean yeah it's
pretty much undeniable that Nikola Tesla
was one of the brightest thinkers if not
the brightest thinker in modern human
history just like vegapunk is for One
Piece however as a person he was far
from a great guy if you read up on him I
mean Not only was he said to be
incredibly anti-social and delusional to
a certain extent but he was also a big
believer in Eugenics basically Nazi
philosophy convinced that certain types
of people should be systematically
eliminated and he wrote that in 1935 by
the way bad timing and as I've talked
about before in other videos vegapunk
does share this much darker side to his
character as well yes he has good ideals
and wants to end Wars which is why he
gets along great with dragon I think and
comes off as a genuinely good and funny
guy but he also has been conducting
inhuman and ethically terrible
experiments on humans and other life
forms I mean literally on this chapter's
cover story we have Caesar and judge Vin
smoke thinking about their former glory
days which just drives this point home
even more I think think of Sanji and his
siblings the kids on Punk hazards gas
weapons and all the military assets that
vegapunk has created for the government
including the seraphim by the way that
now literally have come to take him out
this chapter so yeah vegapunk has good
ideals but doesn't mind doing bad things
in the name of scientific progress as a
result I am incredibly curious which
direction Oda will take his character in
and if this will become a major plot
point or not because I feel at least
that Oda has made created a point to
show us both sides of the genius doctor
but for now let's get back to the
ancient energy and devil fruits if there
used to be unlimited power during the
void Century it does explain how a
technologically advanced civilization
was able to reshape the entire planet
and how a war on this level could truly
throw back Society by 500 years now I
already mentioned that the ancient
weapons and the ancient mechanic Soldier
were clearly powered by this ancient
energy but when you think about it this
also means that 200 years ago when the
robot attacked marijua someone had
access to this energy so what could this
be and who was that mysterious person
when you think about it there is
actually one more example of ancient
technology that uses large amounts of
energy the Hidden City on the moon that
Anna discovered they are the remains of
this technologically advanced Sky people
who at some point ran out of resources
on the moon and the dust came down to
earth when I was maybe this was their
attempt at fixing their resource problem
it might also be the answer to why
vegapunk is specifically talking about
ending War for resources because I mean
not to be mean but so far I feel like we
actually haven't seen that being an
issue at all in one piece so far have
there been any wars for resources I
don't think so but anyways this ancient
city on the moon is reactivated by nl's
electricity Powers now I have already
speculated about this mysterious ancient
power source before it could be a form
of nuclear fusion for example same as
happens in the sun which would fit well
with Luffy and his son got fruit and
that way Luffy bringing the dawn could
also mean bringing light in the form of
unlimited energy which I will say I
still do like a lot but it could also be
that NL and his fruit are much more
important than we all expected I mean
maybe the man with the God complex
really has the power of a Gods after all
as we've seen on Sky Pia he's pretty
much much able to generate pretty much
unlimited energy on a ridiculous scale
he was also able to power up this entire
city with one single attack so the guru
goronomi might well be this source of
infinite energy that vegapunk is looking
for or who knows maybe it's the other
way around it could also be that devil
fruits themselves are powered by this
infinite energy which then allows them
to create their incredible Powers I mean
think about it if devil fruits are
actually a technology and not just magic
then the energy for aokiji to freeze an
entire ocean or a kainu to melt must
come from somewhere and so an infinite
energy source powering each individual
fruit which explain this which then
again would make devil fruits Advanced
biotechnology basically again not that
unreasonable an assumption when you
think about vegapang's scientific
research of them actually one crucial
and Incredibly fascinating thing that
vegapunk's research revealed here is
that being subscribed to my channel will
will get you more and better one-piece
contents every single week okay but
speaking of the power of devil fruits
and research on them we of course also
have to talk about the arrival of Luchi
and the Sera theme on the islands and it
does look a lot like all the seraphim
not only have lunarian DNA Kizer whose
light powers and superhuman strength but
also a devil fruit each of them and
since Kura seraphim in this chapter has
his devil fruit Powers I'm just gonna
assume from now on that all Theta theme
based on Warlords with a devil fruit
power will have that devil fruit power
as well so seraphim crocodile will have
sandlogia morya will have Shadow powers
and doflamingo string Powers meanwhile
it does seem like seraphim of people who
have no fruit get one that just fits
perfectly with their own powers I mean
we saw the gym base version had the swim
swim fruit to work perfectly with his
Fishman karate for instance we've also
learned that the Zera theme have code
names relating to each warlord's animal
theme in case you're not aware of this
each of the original Seven Warlords has
some sort of animal reference and the
four that are an echid Island right now
are Kuma seraphim as bear since Kuma
means bear in Japanese s snake which
must be Boa Hancock as shark is jimbei
which means whale shark in Japanese and
S hog is of course mihawk and oh boy for
mihawk I can't wait to see what fruit
Oda gives him to complement his sword
fighting abilities I mean that's just
gonna be ridiculously overpowered holy
uzop I'm way too excited for this okay
at the moment one Sierra theme is
fighting with zp0 while negapong has
given control of the other three to
sento Maru ha it's the sumo guy from
Saba ODI archipelago by the way he's
actually not only the first person to
use Advanced Armament hockey in one
piece but also vegapunk's personal guard
assigned by the Marines now Cypher pole
isn't actually part of the Marines but
I'm still kind of curious to see if
sento motto will actually fight for
vegapunk or will betray him which would
mean that the straw hats would have to
face four of the seraphim which does
sound a lot more like a fair fight to be
honest and if a fight were actually to
happen I'm also curious to see who's
Stussy and Kaku would fight I mean
Chopper and jimbei are with Luffy right
now so probably them but yeah that would
be kind of cool to see but really this
of course purely depends on whether or
not Luchi is actually foolish enough to
try and pick a fight with Luffy like
don't get me wrong I do hope and expect
that Luchi has grown a lot stronger over
the time skip but at the same time it
would make absolutely no sense let's be
real that he's gonna be as strong or
even stronger than kaido a leopard is
definitely weaker than a dragon even if
Luffy should at this point have awakened
his devil fruit if anything I feel like
there's more parallels here with who's
who who also is a former cp9 member and
who ate a cat type devil fruit what I
was happy to see how however is that
Luchi actually used his rokushiki
techniques against Atlas here now I'm
probably not the only one who felt like
these techniques became a little bit
obsolete after the introduction of
hockey but it does look like Oda is
determined to show that these powers are
actually still important and useful in
the story now if Luffy actually ends up
fighting Luffy and Luffy does end up
taking a few hits next chapter or so I
just want you to calm down and remember
that Luffy barely goes all out right
from the start I mean if anything I can
really see Luffy taking a few heavy hits
from Luchi before then finishing him off
pretty quickly but then again who knows
it might also be Kuma who will end up
fighting Luchi after all the real Kuma
is as we now know also coming to eckhad
Island right now and just to throw it
out there it would be kind of sick if
Kuma would actually send Luffy somewhere
again this time around as well even if
I'm not sure where that would be but
still and I'm sure that vegapunk also
still has a lot of tricks up his sleeve
to show us as well especially when you
consider his incredibly overpowered
devil fruit that might be the most
powerful in the story that I discussed
in a lot of detail in last chapter's
review right here so go check that out
if you like